yeah I'm geared toward Rosamond I'm
almost ninety three and i studied
education they don't go big food yet
my name is Peter quad my name is Peter
course and I worked in advertising
agencies on paper I'm 75 but I feel as
if I'm 60 Gertrude and Peter are museum
guides for the exhibition the art of
aging it's a show in frankfurt about age
the main reason they were hired is that
they're over 70 they showed daily that
being elderly doesn't mean in activity
today their guests a student's of
international economics they're the
managers of tomorrow get through drawers
a man and peter course tell of their
lives on the job then and now and they
teach the students what it means to be
old handshake and fingers become stiff
in japan like after the retirement of
age 65 so many people have a starting
own business right now i think future
those than the number which has a number
of people working beyond 62 the number
is gonna increase very rapidly in india
people mostly worked if they die because
in Arabic retired if you translated
rearrange the letters is dying sitting
people they want to die standing
Gertrude Rosamond is the oldest of what
are called senior guides she works two
days a week you should i woulda scared I
think everyone should work as long as
they can if they have fun doing it if
everyone benefits from it the public
companies people then that's just fine
isn't it a river Ganga sister court
order a tranquil retirement wasn't her
thing Gertrude Rosa man once taught
German language compulsory retirement
came at 63 but Gertrude wasn't ready to
stop she started a second career
establishing a toy museum at the
museum's director she worked a 70-hour
week exhibits were dolls from Japan or
ancient figurines some more than 2,000
years old
dad calmed I made my biggest
intellectual error back then perhaps the
biggest mistake of my life I thought I'm
75 and my head shakes and my legs are
unsteady nothing works anymore so she
surrendered her job to another younger
person what so there I was suddenly
unemployed at 75 so to speak at the
exhibition in Frankfurt the young are
supposed to experience what it's like to
no longer be a part of active life and
be unneeded when is one Alicia if you
have to be quick it's like going
upstairs we still get up them of your
comments you are you moving up the
stairs more safely no are you moving
with more awareness yeah yes it's much
more conscious when you're older you're
very aware even though he's 75 course
still has another job at the exhibition
center in Frankfurt he works part-time
in a souvenir shop would that be cash oh
thanks a lot he says seniors are better
at dealing with people and coping with
stress there Gibson there's a really
good comparison that used to be true
back in the day people over a certain
age or pigeon-holed as old and rusty
today we're polished stainless steel
some of the students are skeptical
especially when they come from countries
with high unemployment France for
example this period the presumptive yes
there are active seniors but there are
also young university graduates who have
to take jobs that are beneath their
level of education but it just gets
harder and harder getrude rosamund
doesn't want to hear that exhibition
moves next to Berlin the 92 year old
will be training new colleagues there
and most a real spring chickens they've
only just turned 70